what advice would you give to young
folks whether
we're talking about
sport like excelling becoming great at
grappling becoming great at fighting
becoming great at whatever sport they
take on or life in general whether
they're maybe in high school or in
college what advice would you give them
to uh excel
at that thing they take on i don't know
if i'm qualified to answer this because
i'm only 26 so
you're at the top you said giving advice
to young people
for me i think the two biggest things
are
find something that you're both talented
in and you enjoy um
i think that if you enjoy something but
you're terrible at it it's gonna be hard
for you to be successful
in life at that given in that given area
and it's going to be hard to do
something for long amounts of time
if you're talented at it but you don't
enjoy doing it
it's easy to come in
and
train
hard for a month or for two months or
for a year um you can be very talented
at it but if you come in it's but it's a
different story to come in every day for
five years in a row for 10 years in a
row for 15 years in a row so i think
i think finding something that you're
both talented in
and something you enjoy are probably the
two biggest things for me how do you
find the joy in it so you've been
training insane amount you know
a lot you've been doing it for a long
time is there's is there ways to
rediscover the joy in it
yeah for me initially
it was just
learning new stuff you know you come in
as a white belt and every day you learn
you see a different move and you're like
oh man that's that's awesome
um
and then when i started to compete more
seriously towards my professional career
it was
uh the joy of doing camps and seeing the
result of those camps and beating high
level athletes and then i got to a point
where
i've beaten all the high level athletes
already so
who am i going to compete against
so now for me the joy is just
being
the best athlete i can possibly be until
i reach my prime which i'm hoping is
somewhere between 35 and 40. um so
instead of competing against the other
athletes
i'll be bored already because i already
beat all the rest of the guys
but
i know that now i know that i can be
better in a year from now or two years
from now than i am today and that for me
is exciting
by the way is there some aspect of
teaching that's exciting to you yeah
because you become a
better and better teacher over the years
yeah yeah i i definitely uh i enjoy
teaching and
i used to teach um
a lot before i met john and then i met
john and i was like yeah i just have no
idea how to teach um so that's like a
completely different element of the
sport
you know doing things and being good at
doing things or being good at winning
and actually being able to communicate
those skills and knowledge to
to a vast amount of people is
two completely different things